welcome back to the start of the
afternoon session I'm going to do a
brief introduction and then pass it off
to our moderator Beverly gage as you can
see from the description in your program
this panel centers on the societal
context in which co-education occurred
including society's expectations for
women the expectations women had for
themselves and the culture of the
all-male institution we were joining as
you well know many things that strike a
younger audience is odd about how Yale
welcomed the first women undergraduates
from the facilities to the traditions to
the certain limitations on where when or
what a woman could do or be were very
much standard thinking in the world
outside of Yale so one really can't make
sense of Yale's transition to Co
education without putting it in the
appropriate context we hope this panel
will provide a thoughtful discussion of
those years before Yale went co-ed and
the one of women first came to campus
and will it assess what all of that
meant for women in the late in the u.s.
in the late 1960s many of our mothers
hoped we would not follow in their
footsteps and instead wished for us the
opportunities they were denied so I'm
going to turn it over to Beverly but
first give you a little intro on her and
as you can see in your program to the
full bios are listed there so we're only
going to list a few of the highlights
Beverly gage class of 94
is professor of twentieth-century
American history and director of the
Brady Johnson program in grand strategy
her courses focus on American politics
political thought social movements and
governments broadly conceived in
addition to her AO BA she holds a PhD in
history from Columbia so please welcome
Beverly gage
well thank you all are the microphones
in better shape first and most important
question okay that's wonderful to hear
thank you all first of all for being
here and thank you to the organizers of
Rice especially who did so much work to
put this panel together and I also want
to say a heartfelt thank you to all of
you on behalf of the slightly younger
generations of women Yale students who
followed in your footsteps who would not
have been able to have the experiences
that we had without your bravery
hardwork adventurism and also on behalf
of the women faculty here at Yale I was
at this morning's session and I
appreciated the conversation and
advocacy on our behalf I should say
looking out at this audience it's kind
of a thrill to be up here during the
Yale reunions in May I was a speaker at
the class of 1969 reunion looked very
different from this so this is a real
triumph it's really remarkable to sit up
here and see all of you out there and
it's just wonderful that this event is
happening our task up here for this
panel is to draw back a little bit from
Yale centric discussions and think about
how all of your experiences and the
experiences of the institution and the
broader community of New Haven fit into
some larger political social cultural
intellectual dynamics that were underway
during the late 1960s and early 1970s as
a history professor I teach a class in
20th century American history here so we
cover a lot of this ground I spend a lot
of time teaching this as history to the
next generation of students who I should
note somewhat disturbingly even for me
we're now born in the 21st century
so this
freshmen and sophomores were all 21st
century babies so all of the 20th
century including my own undergraduate
experiences of course yours is now very
much part of history for them and when
we talk about history I actually often
point back to this moment in the late
60s and early 70s when students come to
me with the question of whether or not
we've lived through anything like what
we're living through today but in
particular whether we have ever lived in
a society that was as divided and as
full of political passion as the world
into which they are entering and of
course there are lots of differences
between this moment and 50 years ago but
I think there are some really
interesting and telling similarities to
and so that's part of our challenge
today is to talk about what some of
those might be just to refresh
everyone's memory 1969 through the early
1970s so Richard Nixon had just been
elected president we were really the
peak of the Vietnam War as well as the
controversies over the Vietnam War the
civil rights movement had been underway
for well over a decade in its formal
sense and in many ways by the late 1960s
we were entering a moment of really new
radical consciousness for the anti-war
movement for the civil rights movement
for many other identity movements that
were beginning to emerge one of the most
interesting things that I've been
thinking about in 1969 was sort of the
parallel story to that which is a book
that was written by a man named kevin
phillips in 1969 titled the emerging
republican majority and it was sort of
laying out what he saw despite all of
this radicalization despite all of this
energy that seemed to be happening on
the left and within liberal circles he
foresaw a radical reordering of politics
on the american right as well and that's
become increasingly for historians a big
theme of the 1960's and 1970's and of
course for people who were teenagers and
in their early 20s these were
both thrilling years and I would imagine
terrifying years in lots of ways
1968 saw the assassinations of Robert F
Kennedy and Martin Luther King you were
seeing increasing violence in many
American cities and of course in 1970
you really saw dramatic ruptures on many
campuses in the United States I'm sure
everyone in this room has some memory of
May Day 1970 and that might be one of
the touchstone events we'd like to talk
about here but of course 1970 was the
year of the Kent State shootings the
shootings of student protesters at
Jackson State in Mississippi as well so
if we had to boil it down I think we
might think about the period in which
you all arrived at Yale as a period of
enormous promise and change a period of
pretty serious instability and divisive
nacelle and so we want to think about
the experiences of everyone in this room
but particularly our distinguished
panelists in that vein so to turn to our
panelists I'm going to briefly introduce
each of them at turn we'll have a
conversation up here for about 45
minutes to an hour and then as with the
panel this morning we will open it up
for questions and answers I suppose we
can go from from that end of the table
to this one
we'll start with congressman Sheila
jackson-lee
who is a 1972 graduate of me don't start
with you I'm feeling to my sisters all
right she's busy I'm gonna introduce you
in that order and then we'll start
somewhere else a 1972 graduate of Yale
College she is in her 11th term in the
United States House of Representatives
representing representing the 18th
congressional district of Texas which is
centered around Houston you might know
her if you're an avid c-span fan but you
might also see her very frequently
speaking out in in in the name of truth
and justice on many television programs
and elsewhere one of our most
influential and really prolific
legislators today um next we have dr.
Laura Wexler who is my colleague here at
Yale professor of women's gender and
sexuality studies and American Studies
she is an expert on American culture in
the present and in the past particularly
on women's culture women's history
feminism as well as photography film
Media Studies ethnicity race and
migration public humanities professor
Wexler is one of those people who seems
to have her fingers in many many pies
here at Yale which is wonderful for all
of us also here at Yale I'd like to
introduce Linda greenhouse who is
currently it was a 1978 graduate of Yale
Law School and since 2009 has been here
as the Joseph Goldstein lecturer in law
she spent 40 years plus at the New York
Times reporting on the law and on the
Supreme Court she received a Pulitzer
Prize for her work there she is the
author of many books including a recent
memoir which might be worth checking out
for all the personal details in there
and I'm sorry to say that she has also
been a member of the Harvard University
Board of Overseers but that's the one
blogger is mine next we have dr.
Virginia Dominguez dr. Dominguez is a
1973 graduate of Yale College and a 1979
PhD from the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences she is the Edward William and
Jane Marr gut School professor of
anthropology at the University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign she is an
expert on the United States in a global
context in thinking about how we might
tell American history and other
histories through a lens that is not
simply centered in the United States but
looks much more broadly at what the rest
of the world thinks of the United States
and how Americans might think about the
world she's the author of many books
including most recently America observed
on an international anthropology of the
United States and finally we have dr.
Nancy Vickers who is a 1976 PhD from the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
here she was the seventh president of
Bryn Mawr College I think must have many
reflections on co-education and its
promise and perils while she was here at
Yale she was for two years a member of
the university committee on co education
at Yale she's also a distinguished
scholar of literature and of language
she's written many books as well a new
history of French literature among them
so please join me in welcoming these
panelists so I thought we might start
out with this question of how much when
you were here at Yale you were thinking
about this broader scope when historians
think back about the past we tend to
have this very high-level view we think
about Richard Nixon and the Vietnam War
and the civil rights movement and of
course those things intersect with
people's lived experiences but to some
degree they don't intersect with them at
all in some cases particularly
eighteen-year-olds and of course up here
we want to talk a little bit about where
we were in terms of feminist
consciousness in terms of women's
consciousness at that moment so maybe
dr. Dominguez do you want to start us
off since you have both the the global
scale of thinking about this and the
personal experience I will do my best
was this I was here this morning and the
microphones were not working let me do
what you did can you hear me I'm
probably most unusual here and not
necessarily for what you said about us
but I really didn't live in the US for
the four years prior to starting and so
[Music]
some of the things I remember or
pressure I desperately try not to flunk
out of you
I remember a lot of my friends and
colleagues going on marches Washington
because I remember the Vietnam War well
but I was actually not living in the
u.s. at the time I went to high school
is I think at least some of you know it
was high school in Montevideo to an
all-girls Catholic school so what I
remember was I actually watched the
landing in the moon in Guadalajara
Mexico with my mother on TV I mean I act
I remember that vividly I don't remember
various other things I do remember
becoming an agnostic I said I went to a
Catholic girls school I remember
becoming an agnostic when I was about 14
the principal of the school actually
loved that she then went on to become a
union organizer and social worker after
I graduated so you know I was sort of
following in her footsteps but little
did I know was I feminist I don't know I
really don't know I cannot remember did
I become a feminist while I was here yes
was I feminists beforehand I don't know
but it never occurred to me that frankly
that Yale and/or Princeton would take so
long to accept women because it made no
sense
I do remember Nixon I was really
delighted to hear the results of the
survey this morning because I can say
some things now that I wasn't sure I
could say I remember Nixon I actually
was in graduate school when Nixon was
forced to resign remember that I wasn't
it wasn't college I was afterwards I
remember I actually remember the u.s.
being both male dominated and white
dominated quite strongly but my goal was
really just to survive
not like so well congratulations for
doing that even if it's 50 years later
remember congressman Jackson Lee
reflections on politics then and now I
mean were you so I teach in a program
that is attracts many very ambitious
Yale students who are willing to say
pretty early on you know I want to grow
up to be Secretary of State and they
know that now and that's what they're
doing and it's great it's a little
terrifying I was not that kind of Yale
student were you were you that kind of
yes you said I'm going to Congress and
I'm thinking about politics in this
moment well thank you very much and let
me first of all say how humbled I am to
be here with my sisters we use that
terminology in the United States
Congress for our fellow sisters in the
United States Congress and if I might
simply as I look see the utter power
that is in this room so Yale I do not
want you to be particularly protective
of this list because I'd like to engage
with my sisters who are willing to do so
I think that this is amazing so I just
had to get that out and if you're ready
to do like Marian Wright Edelman said a
Yale Law graduate who said you can
change the world if you really care and
I've just met so many of you think we
can still change the world
I was extremely naive so I think I
culturally represented the public school
crowd but also some of us a sheltered
crowd even coming from the big city of
New York which is where I was born and
raised my first year was at Washington
Square I guess I'm not going to give my
biography but let me just quickly say
and NYU and we were in the midst of a
shutdown that first year as a freshman
and all I could think of is my very
loving but Stern parents seeing me
dragged off in handcuffs and in New York
in the protests and so you know I kind
of protested and then
snuck back in the building to tell the
professor I will get their work in so I
had so I I did have I was and I and idea
was I was someone who was formulated by
the words of dr. Martin Luther King and
never got a chance to meet him but I got
to the Southern Christian Leadership
Conference as soon as I could I was
asked to speak and wanita Abernathy's
funeral on Monday unfortunately another
of our colleagues wife died it's the
exact same day but what I'm saying I was
very idealistic and so the small
newspaper article in the anybody
remember the New York Daily News back
then was the working man's paper working
man working woman's paper that said
there opened up for Yale and I really
thought that I was going for you know a
mission I was going to pioneer really
didn't know what I was formulating but I
knew that I was going to get in the
civil rights movement and I was going
someplace that would help formulate me
so the backdrop of the of the movement
of the Black Power movement all that was
raging at the time now on the on the
idealistic and naive point and the
humorous point and I told Gary this he
tries to argue me down that they weren't
here but when I when I drove up when I
when I drove up to the campus and many
of us should remember that day the class
of 72 71 72 and 73 the with all of the
excitement and not teary-eyed well
teary-eyed family members and the whole
clan came is like three cars but in any
event with every clothing in my
possession and trunks and suitcases and
I promise you I promise you there was a
group of men and I laughed I mean I
guess the survey that was taken and I'll
end on this note we all really take
charge folks so even at nineteen which I
was I really didn't get offended I
really thought it was humorous but they
had this big
ganic sign class of 70 last mail class
and they were waving and I was waving
and I guess didn't get the the magnitude
of their conviction to make a long to
make a long story short I viewed Yale
with the challenges of being a woman
first a woman of color a budding social
activists as finessing and sharpening my
skills was the first time I was off on
my own and I think many of my fellow
students were particularly women the
first time that we got confronted with
sexism and maybe we develop as a
feminist so we developed as a as a
powerful so rights activist black power
whatever we crafted it to be political
scientists lawyer but in any event it's
the place where I face the reality that
everything will not be in a beautifully
wrapped package and that you really are
going to have to fight for it in my and
and I forgive me we say this a lot my
sisters it is truly that part of Yale
that I think has given many of us the
grit to be where we are today no matter
what we might have opted to do and I
diminished noting that Yale women became
because I know what Yale women girls
young women went through to be here
so dr. Vickers in our correspondence as
we were thinking about issues that might
come up on the panel or be worth talking
about you emphasized the idea that
actually this wasn't a moment
necessarily when women had outsized
expectations for what they could achieve
it wasn't actually a moment where girls
young women were coming into an
institution like this expecting that
they could do many of the things that
later generations thought that they
could do so I wonder if you could
reflect upon your experience on that and
particularly what the Graduate School
told you about the role that you were
going to be expected to play in the
world yes that's quite a story let me
say I went to undergraduate school can
you hear me
are we okay went to undergraduate school
in 1963 Mount Holyoke College graduated
in 1967 so I'd like to say that I went
to college in the 1950s but I graduated
in the 1970s and so consequently it was
a time of very rapid change but I came
into it as the daughter of a
working-class immigrant family that had
worked its way to the middle class and
so consequently it came with a lot of
expectations of young women and what was
you know what I was sharing with Beverly
there was a degree to which I had
internalized these requirements so
deeply that I was in essence not even
really understanding that I myself was
though outside the box enough to go to
college and to go to graduate school
that I was bringing with me baggage and
just embedded in me kinds of baggage
that it would take many many years and
indeed I doubt that I'm still all the
way out of them although I have to say
Dartmouth turned me into a real feminist
but
but most of all my sense was that it was
expected that I would get married the
young women who were going in 1963
thought there were two purposes to going
to college one of which was to get an
education and the other of which was to
get a husband and the purpose of the
education was to be in large part more
educated successful talented mother and
if for example if you made your way into
that particular system you found
yourself making curious selections
around things like majors now I my SAT
scores would have suggested science and
mathematics
I majored in French perfume and fashion
I mean that's I'm being silly but not
entirely and and so consequently that
you know that was the direction I
started moving in I had the Wits to
think that I really could do something
with this because I was directing myself
and becoming a teacher now I wanted to
be a college teacher which forced me to
do advanced degrees but I was falling
into the sort of laundry list of what
were the expected professions for women
as a teacher as a nurse as a volunteer
as someone with secretarial expertise
there is a moment that I can't resist
recounting and I may even say the name
of the school that's involved in it when
I was applying to college I was applying
to two of the women's schools on the
East Coast I came from Detroit and in
the midst of applying to those two
schools on the East Coast one of them
Smith sent to sent two of its alumni to
my middle-class family home in Royal Oak
Michigan and and so they came in and
they were checking me out they were
checking the parents out they were
checking the carpeting out and and so my
father in a moment that I will never
forget I mean it for me is the most
extraordinary moment about knowing who
my father
really
was looked up having been very quiet
through all of this and said so tell me
what do smith graduates do when they
graduate from Smith and the answer was
they go to Katy Gibbs this from a
women's college so yes I know it's a
shocker and in all fairness I have to
say this is the school that brought you
Gloria Steinem so don't it's not that it
wasn't a complex place and so I think
that you know what Beverly was
mentioning is just that there was so
much to overcome in terms of growing out
of this I think the critical moment
coming back to what you were saying just
a bit earlier was that turn at the
moment to the co-education of the Ivy's
which is a sort of very complex set in
negative ways in positive ways and then
a real sort of explosion of the women's
movement in the early 1970s which
surrounded as it was by some of the
extraordinary moments of the
co-education of schools like Yale and
like Dartmouth where I spent 14 years
taking it was Rico education it it was
truly shocking now questions about
graduate school one of the things that
was very surprising about Yale graduate
school when I was in it and is simply
that some of the most talented
professors most encouraging professors
the people who thought the most of my
work would also say things that were
just truly surprising for example there
was one who at every cocktail party
would come up and say well you're doing
so well isn't that Rand but of course
you know the women get married and their
careers basically end when they get
married so it's just sad and this was a
department where 60% of students were
women and I think I see Sam Chauncey in
the background is that Sam Chauncey hi
Sam it's one of my heroes
and a panel way back then when I was on
a university committee on co-education I
described a fellowship in the French
Department where 60% of the students
were women and that fellowship was an
exchange program with the Ecole Normale
Superieure in Paris so they sent an
ahmadi on to Yale and Yale Sentinel
manya to Paris every year that was a man
it was restricted to the male students
parenthetically the Ecole Normale
Superieure
is not restricted to men's students and
so having announced this at some broad
panel where we were supposed to be
making I think probably a good
impression I told this story and Sam
fixed it instantly so I'll just wrap up
there but I do think you know we have to
I am constantly reading in myself the
sort of drag on my own forward moving
aspirational energy and and I think as
the generations go by I hope we're
shedding all of that Linda you had some
I got similar reflections and you're
writing about your your undergraduate
years at Harvard so I wonder if you
might build off that but then also speak
a little bit about how those kinds of
things began to change and the role that
the law these were of course years of
some rather significant Supreme Court
decisions in the history of women's
reproductive freedom as well as in other
areas so I wonder he might reflect on
those yeah so so my experience is a
little bit different although I have a
Yale degree it was a degree from here
isn't on a mid-career fellowship I was
10 years out of college so I went to the
other place I went to Radcliffe because
I was too old to apply to yell I'm a
townie I went to Hampton High School
just up the road and the guys went to
Yale and the women made their way to
other places so women at Harvard in
those days were 20% of the undergraduate
it was capped we were admitted by
Radcliffe we were housed by Radcliffe we
were fed by Radcliffe Harvard really
didn't want much to do with us they had
to teach us the classes were co-ed but
the social life was very segmented
because the tuition and room and tuition
went to Harvard but the room and board
went to Radcliffe and we were really you
know second-class citizens in many ways
many opportunities were close to us in
terms of even access to various things
on campus post graduate fellowships and
so on and as I tell Beverley in our
earlier communication was remarkable
looking back on that was how little any
of us had in the way of any kind of
developed feminist consciousness because
the message was you know we were lucky
to be there and we knew that great and
Carrick Lizabeth events were going on in
the country in the world I mean we were
very very conscious of Vietnam because
the guys were subject to the draft this
was pre lottery just everybody was going
to be drafted unless they could find
some other way
and we were certainly very conscious of
the civil rights movement and neither of
those things had anything to do as far
as we could tell with women our story
wasn't wasn't visible at all and to the
extent that we thought we were being
treated unfairly and I and I did think
so and I wrote for the Harvard Crimson
and I wrote many editorials about you
know led us into Lamont the
undergraduate library let us do this let
us do that it was we were being treated
unfairly as Radcliffe students we should
have the same access that you guys do
not that we were being treated unfairly
as women kind of sounds weird to say
that I mean maybe you all understand
this but you know I have a 35 year old
daughter she this is not this doesn't
resonate you know with with her so you
know I think that's one thing to say and
I didn't really kind of
a consciousness penny that's how I went
out of the world of work and it was kind
of interesting I didn't want to go to
graduate school the assumption at
Radcliffe was that you would go to some
kind of graduate school not law school
not maybe medical school more than law
school but Arts and Sciences or
something and my deans were quite amazed
when I said actually I'm gonna go get a
job and I got a job at the New York
Times and very soon after that the older
women at the Times and there weren't
many of them but the ones who were there
were very fabulous had banded together
to file one of the early title 7 sex
discrimination lawsuits and maybe if you
saw the Amazon Prime show about the
women of Newsweek good girls revolt
Newsweek had had the women at Newsweek
had sort of cut the ice there and The
Times was following and we were
represented by a wonderful woman named
Harriet Raab who was was a young law
professor at Columbia and she had a sex
discrimination clinic workshop and she
was the first female lawyer I had ever
met
and I thought wow this is really you
know there's another way to be in the
world and and just the being part of the
class that was bringing this lawsuit was
a very you know consciousness-raising
kind of thing and then you know it did
it did kind of clue me into paying
attention to law and to what was
developing out in the world and I was
one of a handful of young women in the
newsroom and I got some very interesting
assignments and I got assigned maybe the
second year I was there to cover a press
conference announcing a lawsuit against
New York State before the right to
abortion and that was um one of many
such lawsuits that was going on one of
them would have been asleep a cold row
against
in this lawsuit never actually got to
court because the New York legislature
changed the law and the lawsuit became
moot but it got me into the discourse
about abortion and they asked me to
write a piece for The Times Sunday
magazine I knew no law no law whatsoever
but I found these great women who were
in civil rights law around the city who
took the trouble to educate me and I
wrote a piece for The Times magazine and
the headline was it's been widely
anthologized as how I know a
constitutional question is there a right
to abortion and of course I argue the
answer was yes and this was 1971 Roe
against Wade was two years away but it
you know kind of brought me into a
consciousness of activism but I have to
say in my undergraduate years was
totally missing so undergraduate years
and women's studies I mean how are
today's students taught in the context
of women's studies in women's history
about this really critical period from
the late 60s into the early 70s what
would you say is now kind of the
standard narrative and how did they
think about it and respond to it okay i
yeah I I want to start actually brought
a problem I don't think I want to read
to you from January 19 1968 I'm not a
member of any of your class but that's
not because I didn't try
this is from Miss Laura Kaplan Sarah
Lawrence College Bronxville New York and
that's to her dear Miss Kaplan we have
received your recent inquiry and wish to
let you know that at the present time
the only women admitted to the
undergraduate programs in Yale College
are the wives of Yale faculty members
and the wives of Yale graduate students
should you be interested later in
applying for admission to one of the
graduate or professional schools in Yale
you should write to the Dean of the
School in which you are interested for
further information Sincerely Yours John
Muskaan's jr. director of admissions
this was weeks before admissions was
open to women at Yale okay and my
special advisor at Sarah Lawrence
College who was Jackie Matt Felder later
became president of Barnard new alga
Wasserman and knew this was coming and
actually I'd had a lot of discussions
with Jackie about it so I knew that Yale
was about to make this decision and yet
the answer I got when I inquired about
how to apply was not well just hold on
for a few weeks it was well you could
marry a Yale man you could apply later
when you're thinking about graduate
school and that seemed it's not it's not
a joke
and I do now have a gale degree because
I when I became if you become a tenured
professor at Yale you got a Yale degree
you can't be a Jenner professor at Yale
without a Yale degree only the best
greatest yeah but I put it on my door
when I became chair of women's studies
and co-chair of the Yale faculty forum
and I intend to donate it history
archived here but it it frames how we
were seen okay and that it seemed okay
to answer an inquiry
for admission that way is kind of really
important because it shows that for
whatever one of these places here
elsewhere that we went we gained
admission but not really access okay not
really access and it took years and
years to learn what was the difference
so I want to answer the question of how
I became a feminist in and around Yale
and then talk about the current students
I taught a wonderful seminar last year
on Coe educating Yale and I'm we had in
amazing discussions with the
undergraduates now and I want to say
some of the things that they think and
some of the ways that women's gender and
sexuality because it's no longer it's no
longer Women's Studies handles this but
I became a feminist in and around Yale
also but it was in the fall of 1969 when
I came to a march to plan the rally in
May the Panthers rally in May and this
happened in late November of 1969 and
there were a number of Panther women who
were pregnant and who were in jail and
the famous and Lind I'm forgetting the
name of the Connecticut case on abortion
what's the name of the Abele against
mark I had just been decided and there
were a lot of feminists who were working
on questions of pregnancy discrimination
abortion access to contraception
information it feels like that feels
like hundreds of years ago but it wasn't
and this group of people the Panthers
the people around what would be the
trial in the spring and people involved
in
access to health came together in the
fall the Panther women created what they
called a women's Brigade and it was the
first time in many years of marching for
anti-war and civil-rights that I ever
marched that they take took the women
out of the general March and put us in
front and we marched as the women's
brigade around New Haven through the
hill through the green and up to the
steps of the courthouse okay and we were
chanting obscenity Yale obscenity
Harvard obscenity Yale get the Panthers
out of jail and it was the exhilaration
of that and the really kind of deep
training by the women activists and the
Panther women in that moment that gave
me the name for what I are he was and it
was the name feminism that allowed me to
recognize myself as a feminist it's not
that I changed it's that it got a
category in the world I subsequently
lived my life in and around Yale and New
Haven and I used to drive around the
green for like years like for 18 years
trying to figure out about a particular
moment that happened the women were on
the steps of the courthouse at the end
of this March we were being we were
gleeful we were exhilarated we had found
companions there was going to be
something to be done about this
situation and people were taking our
pictures in front of us and somebody
pointed up to the left on a rooftop and
said look are those guns or cameras
whether or not there were sharpshooters
on the roof whether or not there were
guns or cameras aimed at us we never
knew and I spent years driving around
the green till I finally figured out why
I couldn't reinfield
it was because the kinetic
Financial Center they took that the
building is gone and the Connecticut
Financial Center is there so you can't
recreate the geometry but that moment
was my deepest political education and
it happened in town not in Yale and it
was directed by the women Panthers and
activists from all over New England who
came to try to figure out what to do
about the women Panthers who were
pregnant and in jail and what I would
argue and what I tried to do with in
Women's Studies here at Yale women
gender and sexuality studies which is
very important to recognize that that
has changed is give some permission for
that wider world to happen within the
university as well as outside of it odd
Adrienne Rich wrote an essay around that
time towards a women's centered
university and it articulated what kind
of university would have to come into
being in order for there truly to be Co
education so the women's students now
and the men's students and the people
that are gender fluid and don't go by
those designations do not actually think
that co education has happened they
think it's a work in progress and they
think that they still are not seen the
way that they would like to be seen as
the education part of the co ok think
about the word co-education cola means
together and for much of though that
first year there was a lot of debate
about how the men and women students
should or shouldn't or could or could be
or not together but it's the question of
education that was really key the
question of what difference did it make
not to Yale not to the dorms not to the
bathrooms but to the country that we
were all here together and I would argue
that momentarily for a short period of
time
co-education descended on yale on the
green for a little while and then it
left that it appears occasionally when
we are seen as citizens needing an
education rather than as men or women or
whatever else you want to be trying to
struggle about how we live together so
that's what under my hand women gender
and sexuality studies tries to be about
people are yearning for this education
people are yearning to be seen citizens
together and that's what I think it
means well I want to pose one more
question to the whole panel before we
open it up to the audience and that
really is the comparative question that
I raised at the in my introductory
remarks what can we learn about the
present by looking back to this moment
of of the late 1960s and early 1970s and
really moving forth into the 1970s the
1970s seems like a very paradoxical
decade in retrospect in which you both
got really the rise of feminist
consciousness the rise of very powerful
women's movement changes in ideas about
sexuality about sexual identity
liberation movements flowering and then
it was also a decade in which you saw a
very powerful conservative movement
taking hold
really culminating in the election of
Ronald Reagan in 1980 these things were
happening simultaneously
they were often clashing with each other
they were constituting each other and it
seems that we may be back in in a moment
perhaps a little bit like that where you
have powerful energies on all sides it's
not clear
as it wasn't in the 70s which of those
energies might win out and I think for a
while we might have told the story of
the 60s into the 70s as a kind of
progress story is a simple progress
story from a kind of liberal liberal
perspective is that still how you think
about those years but really this
question of comparing then and now and
particularly what do we what we might
take away from this earlier moment that
might tell us something about today and
really anyone who wants to jump in on
this yeah I jump in on this this may not
be what you want to hear and there might
be disagreement among us I think we lot
of us who were very I don't know if the
right word is naive innocent some of us
were 18 when we came in you were 19 I
was 17 we really thought we were going
to change the world and I think a lot of
that has to do with all of these other
things also happening in the 60s as I
tell my students now I'm still teaching
we proudly exaggerated how much power we
had then they vastly underestimate how
much power they have now this is both
the men and the women I remember a year
ago in a class I was teaching or about
50 students in class I said I was
getting more and more agitated and I
said I said okay I was sort of talking
about politics power and I said well how
many of you feel you have any power
no hands went up I repeat it I said no
no how about slightly two guys who meant
that mostly women a class two men raised
their hands up to about here and class
and I said okay let's start with you two
and one of them said I I think I have
some power over myself I don't have any
power to affect anybody else or anything
else and the other one said just like
him and that was it so I don't know I
have taught him many universe
cities both in the US and abroad Yale
may be different but I don't think so
not in this way the other thing I have
noticed over the last I don't know 10 20
years is more and more of the women
students resist the label feminist so
they may say I'm a post feminist they
may rephrase the question do I believe
that women should have all the rights
and access etc yes and I say that
doesn't make you a feminist nope so I
actually think we're going backwards and
you may not want to hear that but I
think we're going backwards I've been in
the Academy my entire life I think we're
going back no I'm just come I have to
say that every time I watch the news I
say to myself
good grief here's what I worked for my
whole life and we're going to lose it
and you know I don't have much more to
say than that but it is truly upsetting
I'm more upset and depressed in the 60s
and 70s we had the sense that we could
do something to fix it and here I'm
looking at congressman Lee and what
she's trying to do you know and you hang
in there despite any amount of pushback
which is so admirable but I just I'd
love to hear what you have to say about
this but I just wish I could have the
same so maybe I was just younger you
know who knows but the kind of energy we
had during those years around many many
important causes and feminism certainly
being one of them
seems to me to be somehow lost and I
sensed that we're moving backwards well
you've given me a very good opening and
let me build on your words and Laura's
words in terms of and the moderators
words in terms of this comparative
bubble that we're in I to build on what
I said coming in naive but coming in
believing that I was going to be a tree
shaker and a change maker in terms of
having gotten into Yale in the first
place from the very meager background
that I came from
I am I I built she was you were in 69 we
had not gotten there yet but we were in
70 Laura you wouldn't spring of 16 he
was saying 69 or 70 right but but you
were here from
right so I'm gonna speak from 70 which
was the time when the Weathermen came
and it was in the backdrop of the Bobby
Seale trial as I recollect and Kingman
Brewster made the decision to keep the
university open for those of you in
classes 71 72 and 73 was in the backdrop
of students being killed at Kent State
literally shot dead on the campus it
could have been a catastrophic similar
to 69 catastrophic implosion if you will
but we many of my fellow women students
who were in their own movement myself
was in the Black Power movement when I
say that with the african-american house
with the black Students Association and
you know other groups of colored Native
Americans etc this became the center
point of persons converging sort of the
children of the Great Society who had
benefited but yet hated Vietnam were all
coming to this campus I still maintained
the sense that we were in the midst of
change even though Richard Nixon was
president we still had that hope that we
could diversify we could get an African
American Studies program which we did
Yale should be very proud of being the
mother
of african-american studies and gave
birth to dr. skip Lewis gates that many
of you Lewis skip gates who Waverly he
can he can you can tell him I said
Waverly went off to Harvard but in any
event has an outstanding international
and national program on history but came
out of he came out of this that was a
male student but I but I'm saying is
that I felt in our experience in that
time it was a changing time it was an
explosive time in your time they were
marksmen that we hoped that we could see
right on the campus there was some
dispute with my one of my sisters here
that said they were outside I saw the
the National Guard on the inside meaning
when I say that inside the band inside
the parameter of our campus standing
side by side because they were expecting
the Wedeman I used that description to
say it was a colorful moment but it was
a moment where we thought that we were
there really driving the political
change of the nation that we were
standing up to what we thought was an
unfair unfair trial of a black panther
and I'm glad she talked about pregnant
women I do a lot of work on that
pregnant women incarcerated so for me I
was infused with change and I was it was
growing I was a deacon in the Yale
church for the very reason just to hear
Sloane coffin talk about the the
biblical connection so he really was
societal he helped me go and work for
the Southern Christian Leadership
Conference and so during the summer
breaks you know loaded with what
happened in the spring of 1970 loaded
with that ready for change and realizing
that they were african-americans blacks
in the south spite of this Voting Rights
Act who were frightened and panicked
about voting and we went down to
register people on plantation which
existed where sharecroppers were I was
infused with that spirit
I think that that we have a challenge
because I compare 69 which maybe candy
canes bubbles in water compared to where
we are today and this is an important
moment and pause in the the driving
spirit that I have which I'd like to
attribute to family but I'd like to
think it is to these moments that I had
on this campus too bad that we had this
long period of time we've all gone off
when I look at the array of power as I
said but I must get this in before the
questioning there is the toxicity that
exists now as I said before that I don't
know could even compare to 69 in 69
whether it was feminism otherwise it was
in front of us and we said we can do
something about it
I think we have been as wonderful
parents and adults we probably have not
been as constructive in infusing in that
debt that that rush for those who are
younger that let me give you the faith
of black lives matter let me give you
the faith of March for our lives let me
give you the faith of those we're now
organizing as young as seven and eight
and nine on climate change there is
something there we shouldn't be so harsh
on ourselves but I do think what we
still have the opportunity to do is to
remedy the fact that we're in 2019 and
the Equal Rights Amendment has not yet
been passed so what were we doing just
introducing it and introducing it we can
remedy the fact that although the
preciousness and the little book called
the Constitution should be in
everybody's purse like Barbara Jordan
taught me and shirley Chisholm we we're
not and so our faith gets weakened when
we see the massive reconstruct of what
has been the model of democracy with all
of its warts and so what I would say is
the comparison is
that as we looked for it in 69 we
basically were looking forward and
saying I know we can make it different
whatever our sphere was it might not
have been perfect the treatment might
not have been perfect but I still had
hope coming out of 69 70 that we were
going to be change makers and whatever
we're doing to compare it now but I want
to say too if we don't react the fire
the world is watching whether or not we
are collapsing what they have come to
know as a marker for democracy for human
rights for the unempowered one man know
that Yael gets sensitive but one man is
trying to deconstruct and he's
deconstructing the treatment of women
the respect of women the dignity of
women one man one man another man is
adding to that by refusing to pass the
bill that I wrote the Violence Against
Women Act that has been renewed year
after year of the year when it's expired
so I have tried to maintain you ask the
question how can we do it women in the
United States Congress others in the
United States Congress who are there who
look like we're in the midst of a fire
it is every day we're meeting and
reminding ourselves of the major burden
that we have that we don't consider a
pain a burden to put it back together to
not let them get the best of us them not
let them get the best of us let America
get the best of us forgive me for this
but we live it every day and I still
have to push forward to carry that 69
fever that that that colleague that they
weren't colleagues fellow students
that's standing out in the midst of 1970
when this university was shut down and
opened up to every manner SDS weathermen
black power every other group that came
and we survived it and I'm glad Virginia
is here because though t know women are
merging
Native American women are now in the
United States Congress for the first
time in numbers but where we were we
were surging because we believed that we
could be change makers if we don't leave
here in whatever category of life that
we're in and get that little fire so
that we can spread it across the nation
I don't want to see us again on the
other side of 2020 when we should have
done our jobs forgive me for that
editorial comment but that's what I see
that's what I see that's what I see and
I'm saying let's go together let's go
together do you want to add anything
before we say there there post-feminist
there post-feminist for a long time 2008
things shifted again when very
fundamental questions could again be
asked I will say that you know Susan
Faludi wrote a book about backlash and
right soon after this period of time in
which she traced it's it's not only that
we didn't fully do our job or we
couldn't keep the burden of it going or
people got hurt in those times and
actually also needed a break
all kinds of things happen at a time
like that there was active resistance
there were there are students at Yahoo
we know we're being advised well you
don't want to don't major in what
Women's Studies you don't want to have
anything to do with that you don't and
that went on for a really long period of
time and in 2008 there was a palpable
shift where students really wanted to
know why you know why what the why the
crisis happened why their parents are
the parents of their remains lost their
house what there was to do about it
began to ask this those fundamental
questions
so I don't think the students are
post-feminist here now they were it was
very hard to talk to them what happens
is what you described going out they go
out to work and they come back and they
say oh my God why didn't you tell me and
we say well you know we're here we're
here we're here I think there's
something very important about that I
honor that actually young people come to
Yale with dreams
some of them dream that things will be
easier for them because of Yale
some of them dreamed this is a magic
palace with all of these stone buildings
and it will change their lives I that
dream has to be honored that dream gets
broken and feminism has to be there both
to honor the wish to transcend the
contradictions and pains of our society
and to be there to say well no now you
see that didn't work
that's okay let's see what other people
have thought about it so I don't think
it's a post-feminist
time at least at Yale I think people are
disgruntled I think they feel that
things are not working out right or
they're right about that but I don't any
long I think post feminism at least in
the classes that I get near isn't there
to and add anything briefly I want to
make sure we get to the crowd well just
it's kind of briefing me maybe one way
of phrasing the unfulfilled goal so
looking back at the Harvard and
Radcliffe or the entry of a relatively
small number of women into Yale so the
default mode of course was male and male
was the norm and women were the
deviation from the norm and maybe you
know the smart girls in high school now
and girls run things in high school now
they don't
thinking that they are not the norm that
to be a woman is not the norm but
they'll find that that out pretty
quickly that the default mode is male
we're seeing that play out in our
politics now and so on so maybe a goal
that we can draw from our own lived
experience going forward is to try to
create a world where the default mode is
to be an adult person in the world and
it's not the assumption that that it's
it's the male leadership it's the male
running the running the show and and and
I think that was certainly probably what
most of us felt and what many of us
learned in the real world once we want
to be left the Ivy League so I want to
take the chance now to open up the
conversation I have two requests one is
that you introduce yourself and maybe
your year from Yale to is that
particularly given the nature of the
topic we avoid making long political
speeches and maybe and we'll try to take
a few questions and comments in a group
and then open it up to response up here
there any Nomi hands you know we have
one starting out right here in the
middle I think there's a microphone the
microphone comes away coming I loved
your last comment about maybe to
introduce yourself Judy Silberstein
brantford 72
I loved your less comment about maybe it
won't be about women or men in the world
but adults could you comment on what the
change now is in what it means to be an
adult because I don't think even though
we're in a more male normed adult world
it the male isn't the same male that was
back in our day or our parents day our
grandparents do and particularly those
of you who think about
gender and sexuality what does it mean
to be a non gendered adult today versus
at another time there any other queries
a question okay yeah wait a second let's
just get a couple of comments and then
we'll and then we'll open it up I just
want to amp thank you for your question
oh I'm Patricia Joyce Smith Carter and
I've worked under all those names so
that's why I named them all Moore's 1971
I want to amplify on her question I'm
kind of wondering how or if that passion
that we all had in the 1969 when we came
here still exists and I'm also very
troubled I mean I feel strongly that we
should have a feminist movement but I
also feel that men and I'm not a man so
I can't make them do this but I would
love to see men exploring what it means
to be a man you know i mean i i'm seeing
bullying I'm seeing intimidating I'm
seeing predatory behavior and to me
that's not a man and I wish men would
start to ask if that if that can be
something they look at we had one more
hand right there yeah I'm Julia Preston
class of 1973 my question is about women
and power our activism was
anti-establishment in 1969 civil rights
movement the Black Power movement we
were on the outside hurling ourselves
against established power and I feel
like to a certain extent that framed our
activism and our participation for
throughout our lives
and so my question I have a question for
the congresswoman which was at what
moment and why did you understand that
your role was to gain political power
and anyone else who wants to answer that
question
Nancy Vickers for example how are the
women at Bryn Mawr thinking about their
ship with political power how important
was it to have political power where do
we stand on that today all right maybe
let's start with that question and then
we'll hear some more reflections about
men masculinity but either Nancy Vickers
or congresswoman Lee you know there
there still remained to this day many
great virtues to the women's colleges
and one of them is that they do tend to
be very politically engaged they can be
still yet more politically mind you I
left Bryn Mawr in 2008 so a decade has
passed certainly the ethos has changed
under the weight of social media but I
certainly do see as I listen to the
current president of Bryn Mawr someone
who is working hard with an enormous
amount of forward pressure in terms of
making the college a politically more
responsible and more active place so so
consequently I think you know at least
within that cohort they are graduating
strong they have great ambitions and
many of those ambitions are political I
thank you for the question
I think it was you know there there many
spheres of influence and power and
certainly for a long time
Yale drove people toward the corporate
boardroom in corporate America and you
wound up on Wall Street and you move
money around that was Yale's
one of one of the Ailes pathway along
with Ivy League's in general academics
academics came in and Social Policy came
in but I think in getting out of Yale
and going on to law school and Beyond
and back home one began to see that
change came by someone having money to
change to make a change but it also came
by in
age Minh and changing the political
construct and so just to make a
difference I think was my viewing the
political process as one to be engaged
in now the politics comes in many forms
it didn't hit me really early on because
as a lawyer I wanted to just assume the
bench and be quiet and you know proceed
on as something that I loved it was a
series of ironic circumstances after I
relocated the death of Mickey Leland
Congress person who had a major focus on
helping the unemployed in Africa and
died in Africa trying to provide food to
starving Ethiopians and eretrians but in
any event that set my pathway of
opportunity to become elected just by
having to come behind that tragedy in
our community I just knew that I want
whatever I did I wanted to make sure
someone's life was better and I still
see that in young people today they
they're not I think what they miss is
having gone through what we went through
and what we know and what we see and I
think it's our obligation to teach them
but my I was framed by my exposure to
Barbara Jordan I was framed by my
exposure to shirley Chisholm in
perspective by congresswoman Schroeder
out of Colorado I sat next to her as
only one other member of 2/3 of us on
the Judiciary Committee three women when
I came and they told me that I wasn't
going to be on any other committee but
judiciary because my predecessor one of
my predecessors Barbara Jordan was on
the Judiciary Committee we went through
what we call partial birth abortion
that's how long I've been that was the
attack on something so outrageous but we
as the women we were called names
ridiculous names because we were the
ones you know just going against these
men about how ridiculous it was for you
to try to outlaw a medical procedure I'm
just using this to say that helped gel
me even more so I think you do have to
have experiences to say I've got to grab
power in some way and I've got to be
good about that power so that I can do
good things and I think anyone in here
should think about that even more now
because I really believe out I'll going
in and out of feminism our having it
then moments where people say well why
are you we're equal I think now more
than ever we need to be teachers as well
as actors and purveyors of the truth we
need to be activists we need to be
politically empowered but for me it was
how do I change how do I be a change
maker even as a young mother how do I be
a change maker and we need more people
thinking how can I be a change maker and
use political power but have your life
experience be part of that political
power I think we will be a better for it
as a nation can I can I add something
this is not a disagreement but Julie I
think you said wasn't our passion
anti-establishment anti-establishment
yeah right I understand that but can you
think of a period of time including now
when that is not when when there isn't a
reason to be anti-establishment we don't
use the terminology but I mean really
I'm sorry in this group really who's in
power in this country
[Music]
yes I know so why then and not now I
haven't figured it out
backlash maybe but I haven't figured to
do it I agree I agree do you want to
reflect on some of the earlier questions
as well well I just say there's many
ways we all have different ways we can
exercise power not only in over politics
but you know we live in politics and
I'll just say my daughter is a filmmaker
and she has a big project going and they
were supposed to film in the state of
Georgia which has a billion dollar film
industry because they give deep tax
breaks to film producers and George had
passed this horrible anti-abortion law a
few months ago and my daughter said
actually I'm not taking this twenty
million dollar project to Georgia I
refuse to go there and the whole thing
had to pick up and go to Calgary Alberta
so you know that's what's an exercise of
power